bonjour philippe pottin j'ai 60 ans je
suis commercial depuis au moins 25 ans
et je suis élu au département et tandis
président délégué aux sports
mon canton c'est le canton 21 sur saint
pierre qui comporte t as ste là où je
suis né depuis 60 ans c'est pour ça
aussi que je suis attachée à sucre à ce
canton là et puis il ya aussi
la ligne paradis ni à basse terre et
aussi de la ravine blanche
mais déjà je voudrais continuer ce qu'on
a fait depuis le mandat précédemment la
cie à tous surtout à continuer à aider
les ligues les clubs les petits clubs
aussi les comités et on va porter notre
accent principalement aussi sur les jeux
des îles et puis aussi sur les
olympiques ou 2024
pour connais pas moi parce que je suis
quelqu'un de très social donc j'aime
aider mes compatriotes que des gens qui
m'entourent et le département m'a permis
de faire cette mission